[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti ea tutte di oggi
vorrei parlare con fori un tema
importante e serio posto perché vorrei
ragionare con voi organizzata di stampo
mafioso
quindi vorrei farla con forti mafie e
mafie qui oggi al vivo vi chiederete
e che cosa c'entra il conto alla
rovescia con le mafie
cerco di rispondere alla prima domanda
perché in realtà a questa prima domanda
che ha potuto rispondere a vecchie
all'università quando con alcune
colleghe abbiamo
l'idea abbiamo pensato di studiare le
mafie all'università e alcuni
ricercatori ma sti con il problema
perché dovete studiare le mafie
all'università a ferrara e casomai è
anche alla sede distaccata di rovigo non
siamo mica palermo non siamo a napoli
non siamo né milan a reggio calabria
dunque perché occuparcene
allora dovremmo fare perché le mafie
in realtà non sono confine ha perduto lo
stereotipo più diffuso sulla criminalità
organizzata riguarda proprio questa
distribuzione del fenomeno su scala
nazionale
perché l'idea più diffusa
secondo l'idea più diffusa le mafie
esistono solo nella regione in solitaria
medile ormai da tempo processi senza in
sé definitive ricerche sociologiche
studi sul campo dimostrano che la
criminalità organizzata è diffusa su
tutte le regioni del nord
ora dovrebbe comparire una mappa ecco
che è stata elaborata da un centro di
ricerche
[Musica]
il centro si chiama cross è un centro di
ricerca specializzata sulla criminalità
organizzata da diretto dal professor
nando dalla chiesa
questo centro produce dei report ogni
tre mesi che poi consiglia anche alla
commissione parlamentare antimafia e
questa è una mappa che trovate nel primo
report il primo rapporto prodotto
qualche tempo fa come vedete c'è la
distribuzione della presenza mafiosa in
tutto il nord e vedete che ci sono dei
diversi numeri che sono gli indici di
presenza non tenete che ci sono dei
colori più scuri e lì significa che c'è
chi presenza mafiosa con ci sono dei
colori più grande più leggeri più chiari
a scendere di significa che ci ha di
meno guardate rovigo rovigo non anni
dice inoltre senza all'indice appena
superiore all'ultimo quindi significa
che non presenza c'è già ed è radicata
non come a milano come a torino ma c'è
già
ecco perché così a rovigo perché siamo
qui a rovigo oggi ma potremmo dire
guardate l'emilia romagna
insegno quindi abbiamo pensato e proprio
caso di occuparci abbiamo messo in piedi
questo laboratorio che si chiama
laboratorio macro è un laboratorio di
studi interdisciplinari perché lavoriamo
assieme in tanti sulla criminalità
organizzata e sulle mafie e ci siamo
detti
potremmo fare la nostra parte con
università formando per bene gli
studenti perché è importante più giovani
gli studenti quando diventeranno nel
nostro caso studiamo diritto quindi
diventeranno avvocati magistrati notai
amministratori consulenti legali
d'impresa è importante che sappiano
riconoscere il fenomeno che allora
questa idea l'abbiamo tradotto gli
obiettivi
il primo obiettivo è appunto la
formazione degli studenti e durante
l'anno accademico organizziamo decine di
seminari di formazione invitando esperti
di competenze diverse per fornire le
competenze necessarie anche agli
studenti appunto con la loro obiettivo
invece la ricerca continua perché le
mafie
esistono almeno da 150 anni ne abbiamo
le prime insieme resistenza al fenomeno
mafioso che risalgono addirittura
all'inizio dell'ottocento a metà
dell'ottocento quindi moltissimo tempo
che vi servono ma le politiche anti
mafia invece sono nate molto più
recentemente sono molto più giovani
nelle mafie e quindi hanno bisogno di
continue degli effetti avevo bisogno di
continuare a lavorarci
avevo bisogno di studiare il fenomeno al
momento in cui si evolve noi giuristi
per esempio abbiamo bisogno di studiare
le norme per capire si è ora che abbiamo
oggi nei nostri codici nel nostro
ordinamento funzionano bene nel
contrasto alle mafie o se vanno cambiate
o se vanno implementate rafforzate
quindi ragioniamo lavoriamo
costantemente su questo in rete anche
con altre università come vi dicevo per
esempio l'università di milano e vengo
al conto alla rovescia perché conto alla
rovescia c'entra anche con il contrasto
alla criminalità organizzata perché è
importante non arrivare troppo tardi
delle idee piedi da di contrasto e
allora nel corso di queste attività che
abbiamo avviato aspettare
il nuovo quindi nel corso di seminario
nel corso anche degli workshop cerchiamo
di mettere a fuoco almeno due posizioni
costantemente cerchiamo che di far
passare dei messaggi soprattutto con gli
studenti soprattutto agli studenti sono
rivolte alle due sollecitazioni perché è
importante
in primo luogo sapere che si sono chiuse
in un dato territorio significa che ci
sono delle collusioni significa che c'è
gente disposta a collaborare con
l'organizzazione mafiosa e possono
essere le persone più diverse possono
essere politici imprenditori
amministratori
quindi la mafia quando c'è lavora sempre
con altri gli esperti chi lavora nel
contrasto alle mafie da tempo insegna
che la forza delle mafie sta al di fuori
delle mafie non è mai la macchia da sola
che agisce la mafia che agisce con altri
sempre un soggetto che agisce altri
soggetti disposti a compiere attività
illecite per il semplice l'eroe
guardando il personale
la seconda questione la seconda
sollecitazione suggeriamo sempre è di
tener presente che la mafia è un
fenomeno sociale complesso non è mai
limitato all'aspetto criminale le mafie
hanno sempre a che fare anche con altri
aspetti della vita sociale l'economia
con l'organizzazione della comunità
della città con l'amministrazione con la
cultura con il modo di concepire le cose
e quindi abbiamo bisogno di osservare la
mafia in modo complesso di studiare la
mafia in modo complesso
interdisciplinare sapendo anche che la
mafia si adatta ai contesti cambia con
il cambiare della società e quindi non è
mai se stesso o meglio mantiene degli
elementi di continuità ma ne affianca
anche altri di adeguamento alle singole
realtà sociali perché ovviamente si
muove strategicamente e diventa ancor
più complicato cortissima salento si
tratta di un fenomeno complesso e
adattivo possiamo affrontare gli
strumenti per rendersene conto al meglio
io vi saluto ricordandogli e ricordando
c a tutti che dove ci sono rimasti non
ci sono libertà non c'è libertà politica
non c'è libertà di movimento non c'è
libertà di espressione non c'e nemmeno
libertà economica allora che saluto con
una frase di don ciotti che è fondatore
di libera con cui noi collaboriamo
perché macro collabora con libera visto
pubblico e anche con le istituzioni
la magna con il comune di ferrara di
rovigo lanciati dice dobbiamo usare la
nostra libertà per liberare chi non è
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]